you know a few minutes in this hot
spring would leave you feeling refreshed
but what would happen if you camped out
in this foul smelling pool for 24 hours
how could this water improve your health
what could happen to your brain
and how soon could your organs get
cooked
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you spent 24 hours in a hot
spring
humans have used hot springs for
thousands of years to relax and treat
medical conditions
these waters shoot up from below the
earth's surface heated by turning magma
and the water brings sulfuric compounds
that create that fragrant aroma
all that ancient hot rock below boils
these waters to temperatures around 50
degrees
i know it smells but it feels great
in japan authorities recommend you only
stay in some hot springs for 40 minutes
at the most but
what would happen if you fell asleep in
this hot pot
this hot spring looks so warm and
inviting
why could it be so dangerous
well
what lies beneath the waters could be
fatal but
we'll get back to that
while these waters can feel soothing
the temperature might reach near 100
degrees if this spring becomes
superheated
if it got to just the right temperature
this highly acidic water could burn your
skin within 10 minutes
so a whole day
might cook you like a hard-boiled egg
but if this water stayed at a medium
heat could soaking in it replace your
workout
well a 2015 study in finland found that
one hour in a hot spring
could burn off as many calories as a
30-minute walk
unfortunately the sample group only
included men
okay don't get too excited
your body would be working overtime to
deal with the excess heat
that means you'd be using more energy to
stay at a normal temperature
as the hot springs simmer you
the real test of your body's limits
would begin
you need to maintain an internal
temperature of 37 degrees to keep your
body systems working but the danger
starts if your temperature rises just a
few degrees
you could get hyperthermia a dangerous
condition that could have consequences
long after you dry off
you could experience heat stroke or even
heat edema which would make your hands
and feet swell you may not survive
unless you get out and into a cold bath
right away and even if you cool down
there's a chance that you could
experience organ and neurological
dysfunction within a year
during this bath your heart rate would
increase and you would start feeling
dizzy try to stay awake because you
might faint and slip under the water
and keep your nose plugged because
deadly microbes might lurk beneath this
hot water
while most living organisms may not
stand a chance in this heat the negleria
fowlery amoeba thrives in hot springs
this microscopic threat could travel up
your nose to your brain
and within a week after you feel
symptoms like fever nausea and stiff
neck
you could be dead
but while you're in the hot spring you'd
keep sweating and get dehydrated
you'd lose body fluids at about one and
a half liters or more per hour
as the electrolytes and minerals left
your body your arms legs and abs could
start cramping
sending you into a world of hurt
and when you lose control of your
muscles
this hot spring could become a giant
toilet
okay seriously let me out now
now it's just a matter of time before
your blood vessels leak
this could cause violent hemorrhaging
and make you puke blood
and your intestines would release toxins
into your bloodstream
your organs would swell up like steamed
sausages and that includes your brain
if you managed to crawl out of this
cesspool
your body would be a wreck
and that's if things go well
after the 1995 heat wave in chicago 28
of heat stroke survivors died within a
year from complications
and 51
were left with permanent organ
dysfunction and brain damage
the next time you visit one of these
natural wonders
enjoy soaking but remember to stay
hydrated watch your time and keep your
head above water
but now what if you wanted to try this
from the comfort of your own home
yeah what if you stayed in a bathtub for
a week
well grab your rubber ducky because
that's a story
for another
what if
bye
[Music]